[Music]
Newt Gingrich lost the Florida primary
last night and we do a lot of Newt jokes
on the show and if you're gonna do that
and you're in this business is you can
imagine it's crucial to have a newt
Gingrich impersonator on the staff he
was a reluctant at first but I talked to
Andy Richter about doing it and come on
Andy people look come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's shocking I don't know which one's
new and which one is Andy I know what
really need to get into the gym and do
some gel - yeah anyway tonight I thought
would have Andy recreate a bit of Newt
Gingrich's speech to his Florida
supporters after losing last night can
you do this Andy and you're ready to go
well not really I mean I didn't see you
do it come on it'll be fine do it
come on commitment is to unleash the
spirit of the American people to find
new and innovative and positive things
to do them seven days a week to do them
relentlessly to do them without stop to
make sure that we have fundamentally
gotten America back on the right track
and I pledge to each and every one of
you personally if you will reach out
across the country
[Applause]
the bigger the chance to nominate a
conservative
who has gone up before and
I promise you provide become your
president I pledge to you my life my
fortune and my sacred honor this is
about America thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
boy there's one law here it comes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]